the unmistakable and irresistible color
and taste sensation that is the Black
Forest gateau the chocolate flakes are
meant to evoke the deep dark woods and
the cherries the pom-poms on the Bowlin
hoods a traditional hat worn in only
three villages in the area
in tie-back the famous cherry top cake
is one of a range of attractions
including the world's largest cuckoo
clock and beautiful scenery every year
around 400,000 tourists come to the tiny
town and many of them sample the local
speciality of course this couple from
britain are impressed by the original
version a lot of the black forest geckos
that we have at home in England and -
there's one part of it that be too much
might be the fruity bet would be too too
sharp or too overpowering this is
traditionally the cake is prepared with
a generous shot of Kira opps you can
never have too much out for some
tourists merely watching a Black Forest
gateau in the making is a sight worth
seeing they come from around the world
to witness confectioner Yosef Schmitt
Anouk work his magic and hopefully
reveal a couple of his secrets what do
you need well first the sponge cake I've
already made one yep okay we need one
and a half litres of stiffly whipped
cream via Paul Underground's of Stone
list sour cherries Ornish time plus
chocolate shavings as a garnish as Yosef
Schmidt New York sometimes has customers
who drink no alcohol he bakes the cakes
without the Lou cure even if he
personally sees it as an essential
ingredient he can always sprinkle some
over the cake later if so desired
today the cake is always associated with
the Black Forest although it's true
origins remain unclear but for historian
Claudia Hamburg the cake has its roots
firmly in the Black Forest deity is
right by the Black Forest gateau became
part of every visitors itinerary it was
a time when the region was accessible to
a growing section of German society they
would take a day trip to some little
town in the Black Forest which always
included a cup of coffee and a slice of
gateau to contort it at school the
gateau is just as much a tradition and
trademark of the region as the Bolan
hood at maker Gabriella abala is proud
of the region's customs there's no
actual proof that the cherries on the
gateau were inspired by the pom-poms but
locals including gabriella to enjoy the
sweet treat has a special status just
like the Bolan hood it's not something
you make every day and just like the Hat
it's an integral part of public
festivals
although the Hat is only worn in those
specific villages while the gateau
has become a real Globetrotter worldwide
there are countless varieties everywhere
from here in the former German colony
Namibia to South Korea and the u.s.
and back in tiebacks some of the
tourists from overseas are even
surprised to discover they know a
different taste I think that in Israel
it's more tasty
it's better these ladies come from
Singapore where the cake is also made to
a different recipe the layers itself is
are already totally different without
this the cherry is very nice but tasting
the original makes any visit to the
Black Forest worthwhile